c'est une époque d'innovation et de progrès
où les plus grands esprits du monde repoussent les
limites de ce qui est possible et plongent profondément
dans l'impensable mon ami Victor
Frankenstein est l'un de ces hommes Je rêve d'
un monde où l'espoir remplace le doigt où
un homme infirme peut être guéri  remarcher et
si nous pouvions donner à chaque vie
la chance qu'elle mérite Igor aidez-moi à
changer le monde il y a une différence
entre utiliser une machine pour restaurer une
vie et créer quelque chose qui
n'aurait jamais dû exister c'est un mensonge je
trouve votre travail étonnant pourrait  vous en
créez un autre, je me suis produit dans
beaucoup
plus méfiez-vous de mr.  La vie de Frankenstein est une
création sacrée J'ai un rêve avec une
armée invincible d'un million d'hommes
exact tu m'as promis que tout était à propos de la
vie c'est tellement
plus meurtrier
ce que tu fais
[Musique]
toi